days
more russian forces not fewer
are at the border and they are moving
concerningly into fighting positions
this is cause for profound concern
at the same time and as we've warned
previously over the past several weeks
we've also seen russian officials and
russian media plant numerous stories in
the press
any one of which could be elevated to
serve as a pretext for an invasion
this could happen we are concerned at
any time and the world should be ready
for it
it could involve claims about ukrainian
military activity in the donbas
uh false claims of u.s or nato
activities on land at sea or air
even claims of ukrainian or nato
incursions into russian territory
we are particularly concerned about
president putin and other russian
officials their ongoing mentions of
quote-unquote genocide in the donbass
there is no basis
of truth to any of these allegations
this however has not stopped the
russians from advancing these false
claims to include reports of unmarked
mass graves of civilians allegedly
killed by ukrainian armed forces
and statements that the united states or
ukraine are developing biological or
chemical weapons the latter for use in
the russian controlled territories or
that the west is funneling so-called
guerrillas and terrorists in to kill
locals these allegations again are
entirely completely false they are
entirely untrue
these are false narratives that russia
is developing for use as a pretext for
military action against ukraine
in russia in december russian defense
minister sergey shoyu accused nato in
the united states of planning to quote
unquote commit provocations by
delivering tanks of quote unidentified
chemical components to the donbass
region for ukraine's use
these are straight out of russia's
well-documented playbook including from
its previous military incursions in
ukraine and georgia and from
disinformation operations in other parts
of the world including in syria where
russia continues to conduct a
disinformation disinformation campaign
to defend syria's use of chemical
weapons people must treat any and all of
these claims with the appropriate and
healthy skepticism especially when they
come from russian state media sources
and aren't backed up by independent
media reporting
russia relies on confusion russia relies
on obfuscation russia relies on
misinformation and disinformation to
cover its tracks we should all expect
that and we should all be ready for it
with that happy to take your questions
thanks dad um
all right so but you would expect for
the same thing for
claims and
allegations that that you guys make that
they shouldn't just be accepted on face
value and
it is your job it is your job to ask
questions it is our job to offer the
best information that we have available
to us okay uh i have to
run to go to the airport to meet you in
munich so can you just uh
what what do you expect from the
secretary's trip there great you know
small
window that he'll be there but
what do you expect and the trip will be
of short duration but it will be long on
substance uh this will be an opportunity
for the secretary to meet with a number
of his counterparts i expect he'll
engage in a number of bilateral
engagements
i expect that there will be a number of
important multilateral engagements
of course
the crisis that russia has uh needlessly
precipitated will be top of mind and i i
would assume top of discussion uh in
many of these engagements but it will
also be an opportunity for the secretary
to see
his counterparts from europe and other
parts of the world and as we know there
are any number of other issues uh
including uh vienna including what's
going on in vienna including covid uh
including uh broader global challenges
that i imagine will be discussed there
and the last thing is that uh
you you still have not gotten any
indication of when or or you still have
not gotten the russian response to your
response it has been more than two weeks
since we delivered what we call our
non-paper essentially uh our uh
response to the russians that outlined a
number of areas that we think are ripe
for dialogue and discussion where
together if moscow were to engage in
good faith uh diplomacy we think we
could make reciprocal progress on areas
that matter to both of us the placement
of offensive missiles in europe broader
arms control conventions uh transparency
measures stability measures no we have
not received that response uh it has
been promised to us uh when the
secretary and uh
his russian counterpart foreign minister
lavrov uh spoke again yesterday foreign
minister lavrov indicated it would be
coming in the next couple days uh we are
awaiting it we will give it a very close
read uh we hope that there is uh
there is constructive uh feedback in
that we hope uh that the russians are
true to their work uh that they are
remain willing to engage uh in dialogue
they remain willing to engage uh in
diplomacy to resolve this peacefully but
we'll have to see
thanks
a couple of things in ukraine um so
speaking of intelligence um us officials
and others have
heavily pointed towards this week about
the potential start of an invasion
specifically today there was like a lot
of alarm across twitter on in ukraine
last night
it hasn't happened yet so is that
assessment is that intelligence still
valid
are you pushing it a little bit towards
next week can you explain why it hasn't
materialized we've said for some time
now that we are in a window where putin
could order an invasion or an attack on
ukraine at a moment's notice
that has been the case for some time
precisely because this buildup of
russian forces along ukraine's borders
in belarus other tactics and moves that
we've seen have poised have positioned
russia to be able to do this at any
moment that remains our assessment uh it
could take place tomorrow it could take
place next week it could take place
before the end of the olympics it could
take place uh after the olympics i want
to be very clear
our concern has not diminished in iota
and in fact our concern continues to
grow
given that we have yet to see
de-escalation uh and given that
in the absence of de-escalation we've
actually seen escalation we have seen
more forces arrive at the border we have
seen russian forces uh take positions
that uh would allow them to be called
into service for uh an unprovoked
invasion of ukraine at any moment our
concern on this is very high this
morning lincoln also left the door open
for next week and now you're saying it
might be after the olympics is that
backed up with intelligence new analysis
or you're basically simply talking about
the fact that it's not happening today
and maybe it may not happen tomorrow but
it might happen next week i'm not in a
position to detail uh all of the
intelligence that's available to us but
i can tell you this our analysis is that
the invasion
and attack could start at any moment uh
we've been saying that for some time now
uh we're not going to get into precise
time frames but uh the fact remains and
we've communicated this very clearly
to our partners to our allies across
europe and beyond
that the russian federation has in place
now what it would need to undertake an
attack against ukraine and since this is
so um this is so likely from your point
of view it's not um hypothetical to ask
this if russia if and when russia
invades if they do what will the u.s
engagement with moscow look like will is
diplomacy going to be dead or will
secretary blinken will still be willing
to um come to the table and speak to his
counterpart well i'm not going to get
into a hypothetical but i will say
broadly that it would look and sound
very differently uh right now
we still believe despite everything that
we're seeing despite everything that all
of you can see with your own eyes
uh that there remains a window if the
russians are serious
about their commitment to engage in
dialogue and diplomacy for this to be
resolved peacefully
that window
has not closed that window will not
close until and unless uh putin makes
the decision to go in uh of course uh we
think that window still exists uh the
secretary indicated to foreign minister
lavrov uh that we look forward to
receiving the russian response to our
non-paper
and it is our hope that it forms the
basis for
continued dialogue and discussion and we
are certainly prepared uh to continue to
engage in that dialogue and discussion
uh
that is what we're focused on now my
final thing is um
will secretary attend the g7 foreign
minister's meeting during munich our
schedule is still coming together but i
do expect the secretary will have an
opportunity to meet bilaterally with
counterparts and also in multilateral
flora as well
um is there a chance if you get this
response written response by
moscow
today or tomorrow in the coming days is
there a chance uh is the secretary ready
to meet with sergey lavrov while in
europe
the secretary is
ready to meet with foreign minister
lavrov at the appropriate time the
secretary communicated that very clearly
to the foreign minister look the
russians have had our
non-paper have had our response uh for
several weeks now uh the russians have
been telling us their their response is
forthcoming for
a couple weeks now
uh so we look forward to receiving it uh
it will
we will uh review it just as quickly as
we can
so that if again the russians are
serious about what they say when it
comes to dialogue and diplomacy uh there
can be a further engagement uh whether
that is in the first instance over the
phone whether it is somewhere back in
europe uh all of that will be worked out
um but uh we are certainly uh willing
and ready uh to have those discussions
with the russian federation and to
continue down the path of diplomacy but
diplomacy uh takes two and in fact in
this case it takes far more than two uh
because even if the next meeting is in a
bilateral flora forum
we will coordinate closely with our
allies with our partners to make sure
that they have full visibility until
we're into what uh we are doing that we
in turn have full visibility uh into uh
what they're doing and all of our
diplomatic efforts are mutually
reinforcing when you say that you don't
see any sign any withdrawal from the
border is it that you don't see it or is
it that you think it's not happening at
all we have no reason to believe it's
happening and in fact uh we have reason
to believe that forces have been added
to the border and can you elaborate a
little bit when you say that um
these forces are going into a combat
position what does that mean and what
does that mean that they're
ready to attack anytime what kind of
forces can you elaborate so i can't get
into an order of battle nor would it be
appropriate for me to do so from here
but what gives us great concern uh uh is
a couple things uh one uh these claims
that we're hearing of withdrawals uh
we certainly have not been able to
verify them and in fact we have seen the
opposite uh taking place um we are
similarly concerned uh by the fact that
uh the russians in the midst of all this
this is over the course of weeks and
even recent days uh have
put additional forces on the border the
types of forces they would need
to undertake an aggressive action and
attack and invasion and incursion
against ukraine
at any moment and that has been uh our
concern it is not that there would need
to be uh any sort of significant lag
time uh between an order from president
putin uh and russia moving forward it's
a very dangerous moment but it is still
your assessment that president putin has
not made yet a decision about
an invasion we still believe there is
the possibility for a diplomatic
resolution to this uh as long as we
think that window remains viable we will
be open and in fact eager to take part
in diplomacy with the russian federation
if they are willing to do so uh in good
faith uh and
uh reciprocate uh on that invasive kylie
there are um russian troops situated
along the ukrainian borders right now to
fuel a full-scale invasion so again i i
can't get into uh
the various contingencies um what i can
say and what the president said
yesterday is that there are now more
than 150 000 troops a raid along
ukraine's borders that's uh inside uh
russian territory close to the ukrainian
border but also uh inside belarus uh
that is uh by any means uh by any uh
estimate uh a massive number of forces
uh we also know uh that the russians
have uh
capabilities when it comes to electronic
warfare when it comes to aerial
capabilities
any number of tactics they could employ
whether
on their own or together as part of a
broader onslaught so we have considered
all of these possibilities
what we know is that this could take
place now at any moment given what we
have seen uh
a mass along ukraine's borders uh in
recent days in recent weeks do you have
an assessment of the number of troops
that would be needed for a full scale
invasion you just don't want to publicly
share that or where i'm just trying to
understand why
you say that
aggression is it could be carried out
but you won't say what form of that
what form or what scale that aggression
could be well because that decision
doesn't rest with us of course uh if
that decision rested with us uh we would
find a diplomatic resolution to this uh
we would find a way not only to
de-escalate uh the current crisis that
moscow has precipitated but also to make
progress on the proposals we have put
forward at least the areas of discussion
that we have put forward that we believe
uh are ripe for dialogue and diplomacy
that would redown to our benefit uh to
uh address the security concerns of the
transatlantic community and also the
stated security concerns uh of the
russian federation when it comes to
how the russians would use the forces
along the border that they claim are
there for innocuous exercises you'd have
to ask them okay and then just
on resistance you know if there is um an
aggression and invasion into ukraine
does the state department have
um a widespread plan in place for
how you would support
a ukrainian resistance even if that
resistance isn't led by a centralized
ukrainian government because obviously
they may be toppled
so let me make uh
one broad point uh and that is that
again we are doing everything we can
to forestall uh that possibility to
deter to prevent russian aggression uh
it is not our desire certainly not our
desire
to see that in state it is our desire to
see this resolved uh peacefully and
optimally in a way where we can actually
make progress on issues that have
mattered to us have mattered to us long
before the build-up issues that have
mattered to europe that have mattered to
europe long before the build-up and
presumably issues that matter to russia
and
have mattered to russia uh for some time
now
what without taking this hypothetical
too far um what i can say is that in the
event of a russian incursion our
defensive security assistance to ukraine
uh will continue uh and it will be
accelerated uh as you know we have uh
delivered um
hundreds of millions of dollars 650
millions of dollars 650 million dollars
worth of defensive security assistance
last year
the drawdown that the president
authorized in december
of some 200 million dollars
those deliveries have continued uh even
in recent days
to our ukrainian partners we also have
authorized our nato allies to provide
u.s origin equipment to our ukrainian
partners all of that would not only
continue but it would be accelerated in
the event of additional russian
aggression
and that is uh in addition to what we
would do uh to further reinforce uh our
nato allies in the eastern flank and
just
figure out how to give
ukrainians that support even if their
government
is no longer
that defensive security assistance will
continue okay and then just one last
thing sorry um is there a task force out
of this building on ukraine we've kind
of heard that discussed and could you
just give some details on what that
looks like and how often you guys are
meeting and that sort of thing there is
a task force uh the task force was stood
up um uh in recent days uh it is a uh
task force uh that is operating with a
with a a large team that uh incorporates
many of the elements uh in this building
um it is uh
as you know um uh planning for a task
force like this uh has been in the works
for uh weeks now we were able to stand
it up uh on on short notice given uh the
the planning that has uh that had taken
place guess what
linkedin met india's external affairs mr
s
melbourne
a few days ago did he come out with the
impression that india is fully
supporting united states on the issue of
russia
so there was a discussion of uh russia
and ukraine uh in the context of the
quad meeting that we had with uh our
indian counterparts uh our uh japanese
and australia australian allies uh there
was uh a strong consensus uh in
that meeting uh that there needs to be a
diplomatic a peaceful resolution to this
uh one of the core tenants of the quad
uh is to reinforce the rules-based
international order
and that is a rules-based order that
applies equally in the indo-pacific as
it does
in europe as it does anywhere else
we know that our indian partners are
committed to that rules-based
international order there are uh any
number of uh tenants to uh that order
one of them uh is that borders cannot be
redrawn by force uh that large countries
cannot bully small countries uh
only the people of a particular country
can be in a position to choose their
foreign policy
their partnerships their alliances their
associations
those are principles that apply equally
in the indo-pacific as they do in europe
and during the bilateral meeting this
secretary blink can raise the issue of
taxa sanctions or india by s 400 from
russia uh there was a discussion of our
broad uh defense relationship uh but i
wouldn't want to characterize it beyond
that uh one more question india has
asked number of his students who are
studying in ukraine to leave the country
and many of these students have said
they are not enough flights and if the
flights are there they are quite
expensive even as india has assured that
they will be taken care of if there is
invasion
but is there any coordinated
international efforts including by us to
evacuate foreign nationals from ukraine
in the case of invasion well we're
certainly sharing information that we
have both about the threat and the
posture that we are taking these to be
our own citizens uh with our allies and
partners uh around the world but as you
know we have a special responsibility to
american citizens uh and our message to
american citizens for some time now uh
has been that you should leave
and you should leave now using
commercial or private uh private uh
options that are still available uh
recently we have provided uh american
citizens at least reiterated uh guidance
to american citizens uh how they can
travel overland and we have given them a
specific
crossing instructions for specific
border crossings we have worked with our
polish allies to facilitate border
crossings of american citizens we know
that in any number of countries are
doing the same for uh their own citizens
we think this is a
prudent step as we continue to do
everything we possibly can uh to seek to
find a diplomatic resolution to the
crisis thank you yes missy
a couple
questions ned um
so uh
did i miss you saying who was heading
the ukraine task force and can you tell
us
we'll see if we can get you any more
information on that okay
and um i know that um you said secretary
blinken will plan to meet with foreign
minister lavrov at the appropriate
moment
but he's willing to is willing to okay
um in the meantime uh since you guys are
now tracking moment by moment what they
are not doing um around ukraine is the
state department
communicating this skepticism about what
is not occurring to the russian
government
um in in any private way other than
through you know what you're saying up
here at the podium
as you know the secretary has had now
several opportunities to speak to
foreign minister lavrov in recent days
in recent weeks uh the president uh has
now had uh several opportunities to
speak to speak to president putin uh
our embassy uh in moscow is in touch
with uh their counterparts on the ground
uh we have uh relayed in no uncertain
terms uh that what we need to see in
order for this diplomacy uh to be
effective is de-escalation uh the
russians have heard that from the very
start of this process and if i recall uh
even at the outset of the first meeting
of the strategic strategic stability
dialogue uh the dialogue that deputy
secretary sherman attended with foreign
minister yabkov in geneva in january
that was a key message that
we imparted publicly
but also privately that in order for
this process to work we need to see
de-escalation uh
until now that is a message that the
russians have not heeded okay just two
more questions um
and you know they're saying we're moving
by forces you're saying you know they're
not moving any meaningful amount of
forces and in fact they're doing the
opposite
why why do you think they
um are making these claims when not only
is there you know what the intelligence
that you guys are
observing and then talking about
publicly but there's commercial
satellite imagery
there's people who are posting stuff on
tick tock you know why why i'm just
curious about what you think
um their uh thinking is there um
given the fact that it's something that
you know in this day and age with the um
access to
imagery out there in the public that
they think that they could
um sort of get away with if that's what
your you guys are saying well uh you're
right uh that there are russian words
and then there are russian actions and
it should be clear to everyone it is
clear to everyone uh who uh uh takes the
time to investigate uh that their words
uh do not match their actions and in
fact uh their words stand in stark
contrast
to their actions and you can see that
on social media you can see that on
publicly available
satellite imagery you can see that
through any number of memes that's a
question for the russian federation
what i will say uh and this is uh as
much from an historical perspective as
it is from what we're seeing now this is
the russian playbook this is the
playbook uh the russians have used in
the past including in 2014 uh to paint a
picture or at least to attempt to paint
a picture publicly uh while they uh do
the opposite uh
in a way that they
seek to obfuscate in a way that they
seek to obscure uh and to hide uh
this is
not 2014 uh in the sense that social
media is different uh the
there are resources available to the
public uh that were not available back
then but it's also not 2014 in the sense
that
we are standing up here
almost every day
and
offering
uh the context of what we know uh in an
effort to be as transparent as we can
with the american people in the
international public to do two things uh
in the first instance in the best case
scenario to attempt to prevent to deter
the russians from moving forward uh with
what they are planning what they have
planned or what they had planned all
along
if we're not able to do that and
ultimately putin will make the decision
that putin will make based on his
on his own calculus
if we're not able to do that uh what we
will have done is to uh have put a
spotlight uh on the fact that
uh this was all a charade this was all a
show uh and that while the russians were
claiming de-escalation while the
russians
were claiming a commitment to dialogue
that the opposite was taking place and
so that's why we've tried to be very
clear
about the disinformation about the
pretext
the fact that uh the russians did this
precisely in 2014 uh and are growing
alarm uh that the russians may be
planning a similar
uh pretextual
uh
uh
attempt uh in
the coming hours the coming days uh
knowing that it is very much part and
parcel of their playbook okay just last
thing you said that the troop number was
now more than a hundred and fifty
thousand do you have a more specific
number you could provide i'm not able to
provide a more specific number but uh
that number uh has grown uh in recent
weeks and in recent days and as you
heard the president say yesterday
currently stands at around 150 000.
yes
putin could obviously order an attack at
any moment but i just wonder vis-a-vis
the specific date that was put out for
today and the
attack didn't materialize does does that
mean that that specific piece of
intelligence was wrong
i
no it doesn't uh first of all
i don't think you've heard us from
any
uh podium uh point to a specific day uh
of an invasion i think what you've heard
from us from some time now is to make
the point that what the russian
federation has put in place or the
capabilities it would need to order an
attack uh at any time uh but this goes
back to what i was saying uh before into
a discussion uh that uh perhaps we had
quite memorably here the other week
that if something doesn't come to pass
it doesn't necessarily mean that what
we've been warning of uh is wrong uh in
the best case scenario uh the russians
will have changed their calculus i can't
say what has happened uh in this case
what i can say uh is that the russians
over several weeks in in recent days
have put in place
the assets uh the troops uh the material
that they would need to undertake an
attack against ukraine at any moment
we've been in that window for some time
now we will be in that window uh for
some time until and unless we see
de-escalation secondly quickly i noticed
that the russian defense ministry has
issued video showing uh train loads of
armored uh vehicles heading at least
purporting to be heading across the
bridge away from crimea
what do you need to see to be convinced
that there
is
some form of withdrawal i mean
presumably you think that that video is
not true or what what is it that you
would need to see would it need to be
backed up by satellite imagery or
you would need to be verified uh and
there will be sense though
there are any number of ways uh that we
have to verify them and i'm not able to
speak to all of them uh from the podium
but look this is not an assessment uh
that is hours and hours alone you heard
from the nato secretary general this
morning uh jen stoltenberg that we have
not seen de-escalation and in fact we've
seen more troops uh head to the border
so uh it's difficult for us to speak
with specificity when it comes to the
sources and methods that we would use to
verify such a claim but uh we i can tell
you uh that we are pulling every lever
at our disposal uh in an effort to
um
make sure that we have as much
visibility as we can but that sort of
video is propaganda do you think the
russians have engaged in a great deal of
propaganda uh and and disinformation on
this very question and just lastly um
are you concerned or or convinced by the
sounds of it that moscow is pushing this
genocide line to justify invasion and
just why are we seeing that now well uh
you would have to ask the russian
federation why we're seeing that now but
we can say a couple things how concerned
are you uh we're very concerned uh we're
very concerned because uh we know
broadly uh that uh the russians uh are
want to point to a fabricated pretext uh
before undertaking aggression uh it's
precisely what they did uh in 2014 in
ukraine uh these claims of genocide have
haunting echoes of what we heard in 2014
regarding the persecution of russian
speakers in eastern ukraine and crimea
this is
in some ways eerily similar
to
what we have experienced before and so
now that we hear vladimir putin we hear
other russian officials uh pointing to
genocide
uh
pointing to
uh
the
uh
pointing to what you know we have heard
uh in the past uh it gives us great
concern that this could be part
of the same playbook that they are
reprising uh in the context of 2022.
thank you yes
brazilian presidential equals another
match while doing coaching in moscow
bosom did not mention the ukrainian
crisis but he said that he has
solidarity with russia
how do you say his declarations his trip
and the approximation between brazil and
russia at this moment
and if this could affect the relations
between brazil and the united states in
the future
well we know that any number of
countries and in fact the international
community
is broadly and deeply concerned
about what we are all seeing uh taking
place
with russia and ukraine at this very
moment
as
democratic countries
as democratic leaders in our in our
hemisphere uh we in brazil uh we feel
that
uh we have a responsibility to stand up
uh for the values that we
uh and at
the heart of those values
are the principles of uh the rules-based
international order uh these are this is
the order that has uh over the course of
more than seven decades now uh has
fueled unprecedented levels of
prosperity security and stability uh in
europe in the indo-pacific but also uh
in our own uh hemisphere and so that's
why it is our hope that uh president
bolsonaro uh will have uh taken
advantage of this opportunity uh this
meeting with president putin uh to
reinforce uh the very messages that uh
are
enshrined in the values we share um and
that are part and parcel of uh the
rules-based international order again
that applies to the western hemisphere
um as it does to the end of pacific in
europe yes yes and if
he did not uh stand for this value
you can have some consequence for the
relations between the utilizing brazil
in the future i i would leave it to our
brazilian uh counterparts to uh share uh
the the content and context of that
discussion yes
sure anything else on russia ukraine
god yeah on honduras yesterday former
president orlando hernandez was arrested
following a request by the u.s
how are you confident how confident are
you on his tradition moving forward and
why did the state department not
disclose that he was in its list of
corrupt officials in central america
until he was out of office
uh well um i'll correct one element of
that we did just disclose the uh corrupt
officials list but let me get to that um
as a as a long-standing matter of state
department policy uh as you know we
don't comment on matters of extradition
those are within the purview of the
department of justice and i need to
refer you to the department of justice
to speak to uh the process behind
any particular uh extradition uh but
secretary blinken did state uh last week
when we publicized uh the fact that
former president hernandez was included
in the corrupt and undemocratic actors
list uh that um no one is above the law
that includes
heads of state former heads of state and
we take all allegations of criminal
wrongdoing
extraordinarily uh seriously whether
it's in
honduras whether it's in anywhere else
in this hemisphere or around the world
our priority remains
seeing the rule of law respected
implemented
strengthened and supported
by our partners as they work to ensure
judicial and security sector uh security
sectors uh protect all of their citizens
these are discussions that we're having
with our honduran partners but also
partners throughout the region are you
satisfied with his arrest
i
again as a matter of uh when it comes to
the extradition i need to refer you to
the department of justice yes tracy
follow on my colleague here um actually
juan orlando fernandez was not included
initially when the list was released
last year and only recently put on the
list i think last month
um but his question um
are you confident that he that
hernandez will be extradited you know as
you know as happens in many many uh
countries
the uh he managed to stack the supreme
court with his allies
and that is who the honduran supreme
court obviously and that is who will
have to rule whether they will allow the
extradition or not so i'm wondering how
confident you are that that extradition
will take place it again is a as a
matter of long-standing policy um we
don't get into we don't speak to uh the
process of uh any particular extradition
uh so i'd have to refer you to the
department of justice but what i will
say uh is that the rule of law uh
following the rule of law strengthening
the rule of law implementing uh the rule
of law uh is uh a key priority of ours
uh including in central america
we know that uh it is a priority of uh
the new administration there
and i think i'd have to leave with that
the iranian foreign minister is expected
to be in munich at the security
conference
is the secretary ready willing to meet
with him uh directly in person if that
helps having a breakthrough in vienna i
i wouldn't expect uh
at least in munich a meeting between uh
the secretary and the foreign minister
but what i will say
and what we have long said is that uh we
believe that direct talks uh between the
united states uh and tehran
and iran
would be in our interest
in the context of vienna as you know
francesco we have had to operate on an
indirect uh basis with our uh primarily
our european partners relaying messages
back and forth
and that is has posed an obstacle uh in
the context of negotiations that are
technical that are detailed uh that are
uh complex uh and so we have said for
some time now uh that we would find
direct negotiations in the context of
vienna uh to be to our advantage it
would be the benefit of our attempts to
seek to achieve or at least test the
proposition of whether we can achieve a
mutual return to compliance with the
jcpoa the french foreign minister said
today is now a matter of days and no
more weeks to know whether
well to have a deal uh to save the the
jcpoa or to go in a nuclear crisis is
that your assessment too is it a matter
of phase well our assessment is that we
are in the midst of the very final
stages
of as i said before a complex
negotiation
with the key stakeholders here
this is
really the decisive period
during which we'll be able to determine
whether a mutual return to compliance
with the jcpoa uh is in the offing or if
it's not uh again we uh are sincere and
steadfast uh in our efforts to um
test the proposition as to whether a
return can be achieved uh we continue to
believe that a mutual return to
compliance with the jcpoa is the best
way uh to
once again place permanent verifiable
limits on iran's nuclear program
but
we're in a decisive period because uh
that window uh will very shortly have
closed and so have you seen the
political willingness from tehran in
these last days in vienna and when we'll
be able to when will you be able to make
that assessment i think uh we'll have uh
we'll have a much better sense of that
uh in the coming days and it will uh
have to be in the coming days because
again uh we're in a decisive period
where um all sides uh will have to make
the political commitments uh that will
be necessary if we are to achieve a
mutual return to compliance with the
jcpoa
okay thank you very much everyone
[Laughter]
you